hi-yah let's learn English with a new
Lion King movie so if you're anything
like you need the original Lion King was
probably quite a highlight of your youth
and that's why I thought that with this
new version it would make a perfect
lesson for you guys we have some
interviews with the entire cast
including Beyonce and some clips from
the new movie and every week we help the
learners to understand fast speaking
natives without getting lost without
missing the jokes and without subtitles
just like Carmita who says that with our
lesson she has taken her English to the
next level so if you want to be able to
improve your English - we would love to
help you to do it you just have to hit
that subscribe button and the bell down
below so you don't miss any of our new
lessons
look closer he lives in new Lion King
was a story that people knew intimately
Simba the reason the Lion King has
endured is because the inspiration that
we're getting from it is universal it's
a story that remains true to everybody
the songs were amazing just felt like
everything you wanted from a Disney
movie getting to relive it in a new way
is really exciting what's the model
Lion King was a story that people knew
intimately more literally speaking at
being intimate with somebody or
something relates to having an extremely
close relationship with them or a deeper
knowledge about it
I want to spun it really really foster
gave me the ability to fly every time I
threw he'll always come back to me it
sounds like he had a pretty special and
intimate relationship with this hammer
and then losing that was almost
comparable to losing a loved one it's a
nice way of putting it
here jon favreau the director of the new
Lion King movie talks about how fans
feel deeply connected with the story in
the original Lion King movie the reason
the Lion King has endured is because the
inspiration that we're getting from it
is Universal in this case to endure
simply means to continue to exist to
last Alfred what would you have me do
and do a most away take the reason the
Lion King has endured he's referring to
how the original movie has continued or
remained relevant to people even though
it's been 25 years since it was released
it's a story that remains true to
everybody here again they talk about how
connected to the story the fans still
feel by saying that it remains true to
everybody this refers to how its message
and the values are still just as
relevant as when it was released in
other words we can say that the Lion
King is a classic or timeless film the
songs were amazing just felt like
everything you want from a Disney movie
when he says everything you want from a
Disney movie we can understand that he's
referring to all the similar elements
found in Disney Animation's such as
great original music talented voice
actors a fascinating story all while
being very impressive visually do you
like Disney movies what is your favorite
thing about them share in the comments
below and see what other learners have
set a motto is a short sentence with a
rule on how to behave or think that is
used by a person or institution as to
define their way of life for example be
prepared is the motto of the Boy Scouts
all my life my motto has been aim high
repeat after me hakuna matata what ha
Cunha Matata it means no worries
Hakuna Matata Hakuna Matata ain't no
passing craze it's our motto what's the
model with you will solve all your
problems that's right the joke here is
that the pronunciation in the sentence
what's a motto sounds like he's saying
what's the matter it's very normal
considering that with connected speech
the sentence what's the matter becomes
what's the matter when pronounced in a
natural way in English again compared
the two spoken at natural speed what's a
motto what's a matter so as a joke
Timon responds what's a motto with you
which also sounds very similar to what's
the matter with you
by the way if we ask someone what's the
matter with you we are showing that we
have detected they have some problem and
we want to know what it is
however if asked angrily or
sarcastically it's considered an insult
meaning that you are saying that person
is problematic and abnormal so your
dad's in love big time and the worst
part of it is it's with two different
women oh man please tell me one of them
is mom of course of course one of them
smile
okay so I know you're watching this
because you're passionate about English
fluency and so I wanted to let you know
that from now until July 20th
it's fluency week in order to celebrate
giving 700,000 subscribers on learnings
with TV series almost 750 now and to
thank you for all of your support for
all of our lessons we wanted to give you
a really huge opportunity over the next
year to take your English fluency to the
next level with a 33 percent discount on
our premium course fluent with friends
just like clover who says that she is
having a much more real life learning
experience than in school what didn't
you just love this time next year you
could confidently understand all of your
favorite movies and series without
subtitles in English well to learn more
about the course and sign up simply
click up here or down in the description
below and remember to get your three
three percent off just use the coupon
code 700k at checkout and hurry because
this offer is only available for a few
more days I look forward to seeing you
inside the fluency circle and let's
continue with the lesson I'm entering
into Lion King inheriting all that I
learned on Jungle Book there was a
tremendous opportunity to retell the
story using a new set of tools and a new
technology
John just seems to have it all there is
really impressive how he just sort of
holds that all together that I'd really
admire the vast array of talent that's
been assembled for this film
it's a privilege to be counted among
these actors yeah the me comma can help
no son you stay with the other goats I'm
entering into Lion King inheriting all
that I learned on Jungle Book literally
to inherit is to receive money property
etc from someone after they have died
example she inherited a fortune and her
father
[Music]
oh yeah inherited some money from a dead
uncle I did and he was rich as hell to
them so in a way we can say that
figuratively the Lion King is inheriting
John's experience from the jungle book
The Jungle Book is a fantasy adventure
movie also produced by Jon Favreau which
similarly was a remake of a classic
Disney animation there was a tremendous
opportunity to retell the story using a
new set of tools using a new set of
tools
there was a tremendous opportunity to
retell the story using a new set of
tools and a new technology tremendous
means very great an amount scale or
intensity mostly used to also emphasize
how positive or negative something is to
a context a rage and vengeance anger
lost through grethel tremendous
motivators they really clear the mind so
I'm good to do a set of things is a
group or a collection of related things
so what do you say joy you get the whole
set of encyclopedias for $1,200 that
works out to just 50 bucks a book $1,200
there was a tremendous opportunity to
retell the story using a new set of
tools and a new technology he's saying
that this was a great opportunity to
tell the story once again with this new
movie now that we have access to more
resources and more sophisticated
technologies 25 years after the first
movie came out
John just seems to have it all there is
really impressive how he just sort of
holds that all together by saying that
John has it all he means that he is very
talented and capable of doing everything
that is necessary to hold it all
together means to be able to keep all
different parts of a larger hole running
and working together it's really
impressive how he just sort of holds
that all together how you just sort of
holds that all together is really
impressive how he just sort of holds
that all together there I'd really
admire the vast array of talent that's
been assembled for this film an array is
a large group of things or people
organized together vast describes
something that is very great in size
amount degree or intensity to assemble
is to come together in a single place or
to bring parts together in a single
group for common purpose when used with
objects it refers to putting together
different pieces so to mount or
manufacture a larger more complex object
it
in this factory that can completely
assemble a new car every two hours when
talking about people to assemble them is
simply to get all of them in one place
or to work on one project together
example Nick Fury assembled the Avengers
to save the world so here he's talking
about how he admires the large quantity
of talented professionals working
together in this film
I'd really admire the vast array of
talent that's been assembled finis film
it's a privilege to be counted among
these actor ISM let me come I can help
no son you stay with the other Cubs
acaba is a young carnivorous mammal
bears tigers and lions are a few
examples of animals that have Cubs and
then the music there was such a rich
tradition surrounding the songs that
Hans and lt and Tim Rice and now
Pharrell worked on also that's nice to
have actors who are both the performers
and the singers the F Beyonce and
Donnell they present something totally
new and exciting you have to take your
place as king these are real musicians
bringing their creative voices to this
hakuna matata you guys sounded great
also that's nice to have actors who are
both the performers on the singers here
he means that it's nice to have
performers who can work both as actors
and singers instead of having to include
other people just to sing the different
musical parts in the movie as was the
case in the original Lion King
hakuna matata if something is
problem-free you cannot find any
problems in it or it doesn't create any
problems for you example so far the trip
has been trouble-free this has been a
really incredible experience I've never
seen anything made this way before the
level of care where everybody knows how
much it means and everybody's that
invested seeing you again you don't know
what this will mean to everyone I love
the idea of audiences rediscovering
something you know that it's gonna be
very compelling and exciting
we wanted to capture what people's
memory was of this with both the music
and the imagery I think when you could
capture the spirit but show them
something new and surprising it's sort
of the best combo it is time
this has been a really incredible
experience really incredible experience
experience I've never seen anything made
this way before
the level of care where everybody knows
how much it means and everybody's that
invested as an adjective to be invested
in something is to have an interest in
something as a result of a commitment to
it or an investment in it of resources
such as time effort and money example
she's deeply invested in this project
and wants it to succeed I love the idea
of audiences rediscovering something you
know that it's gonna be very compelling
and exciting
if you describe something such as a film
or book or someone's appearance as
compelling you mean you want to keep
looking at it or reading it because you
find it so interesting example
his eyes were strangely compelling
another common meaning to this adjective
is found when co-located with the word
argument a compelling argument is one
that effectively convinces you that
something is true or that something
should be done you could often hear this
in legal context miss Botwin judge
Franklin in Oakland let me get right to
the point your lawyer has presented me
with a compelling argument we wanted to
capture what people's memory was of this
with both the music in the imagery to
capture literally means to trap or take
something by force example learning how
to capture rabbits and other small
animals help them to survive however
here he is referring to accurately
representing people's memory of the
movie example she hopes that the photo
she takes will capture the excitement of
her trip through Europe it became
obsessed with his painting of this woman
who had a blue scarf on holding a baby
and Hanna said that Paine had captured
the essence of that wound better than
any photograph I think when you could
capture the spirit but show him
something new and surprising this is
sort of the best combo
the best combo
[Music]
I think when you could capture the
spirit but show them something new and
surprising this is sort of the best
combo a combo is a combination of
different things normally also implying
the fact that it is a good combination
example this place serves a great burger
and milkshake combo now let's take a
look at a recent short interview Beyonce
did about her part in the new Lion King
movie the wave of gala for me and
exciting because it's one of the only
where carpets that I do with my family
my daughter gets to dress up and my
husband
this year it's Lion King which obviously
got played knowledge so it's the first
time I'm doing any appearance as person
that stars in the Lion King which is
something I grew up watching and I'm so
excited for my kids to see it but it
means even more to share this experience
and this culture of the Lion King with
my mother and my family the wincle gala
for me is exciting because it's one of
the only red carpets that I do with my
family a carpet is a soft type of
flooring popular in homes in the United
States instead of tile in Western
culture the red carpet is a long red
carpet that is put down for an important
guests to walk on when he or she visits
somewhere and receives a special
official welcome in the case of social
events with celebrities like the Wacha
gala red carpet refers to the time and
place when the celebrities arrive which
normally includes an actual red carpet
we talked more about these kinds of
events in this lesson with Indian
actress Priyanka Chopra which you can
check out by clicking at the top it's
one of the only wear carpets that I do
with my family my daughter used to dress
up in my
to dress up is to wear particularly
elegant clothing for example for a
special event or to wear costumes like
on Halloween you're supposed to wear
costume I am I am a woman who spent a
lot of money on a dress and she wants to
wear it because soon she won't be able
to fit into it yes I did
Chandler this year it's Lion King which
obviously I played knowledge so it's the
first time I'm doing any appearance as
person that stars in the line it's the
person that's the Harz in the line team
we say that an actor plays a part in a
movie or theatrical performance as we've
already seen
Beyonce plays the lion Nala similarly
you have probably heard a celebrity
called a star well we can say that the
Lion King stars Beyonce meaning that she
is one of the principal actors in the
movie and we can also say that she stars
in the Lion King example Emma Watson
starred in the Harry Potter movies if
someone does or makes an appearance it
just means that they went to a place
especially briefly this usually is used
for celebrities or other important
people example Obama is making an
appearance at the charity fundraiser
person that stars in the Lion King which
is something I grew up watching and I'm
so excited for my kids to see it if you
want to say that you did something often
or habitually as a child you can say you
grew up doing that thing example I grew
up camping a lot during the summer
[Music]
yoku closer he lives in new Lion King
was a story that people knew intimately
Simba
the reason the Lion King has endured is
because the inspiration that we're
getting from it is universal it's a
story that remains true to everybody
the songs were amazing just felt like
everything you want from a Disney movie
getting to relive it in a new way is
really exciting what's the model nothing
I'm entering into Lion King inheriting
all that I learned on Jungle Book there
was a tremendous opportunity to retell
the story using a new set of tools and a
new technology Jon just seems to have it
all there is really impressive how he
just sort of holds that all together
that I'd really admire the vast array of
talent that's been assembled for this
film it's a privilege to be counted
among these actor ISM yeah let me comic
in hell no son you stay with the other
Cubs and then the music there was such a
rich tradition surrounding the songs
that Hans and Elton and Tim Rice now
Pharrell worked on all so that's nice to
have actors who are both the performers
and the singers the F Beyonce and Donald
they present something totally new and
exciting you have to take your place as
king these are real musicians bringing
their creative voices to this
[Music]
hakuna matata you guys sounded great
this has been a really incredible
experience I've never seen anything made
this way before the level of care where
everybody knows how much it means and
everybody's that invested seeing you
again you don't know what this will mean
to everyone I love the idea of audiences
rediscovering something you know that
it's gonna be very compelling and
exciting
we wanted to capture what people's
memory was of this with both the music
and the imagery I think when you could
capture the spirit but show them
something new and surprising it's sort
of the best combo time
all right I hope you enjoyed that lesson
a lot and that it would be really
beneficial for you and going to see the
new line key movie and remembered don't
miss out on this big opportunity for
your English fluency at a small price
check out club with friends and remember
to use your coupon code 700k at checkout
to get 33% off be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss a single one of our new
lessons check out this playlist of
videos teaching you English with movies
and this other lesson I know that you're
going to love and now it's time to go
beyond the classroom and live your
English aha yeah